क्या हर रोस पेट साफ करना आपके लिए मुश्किल होता जा जा रहा है?
और इस कुन्स्टिपेशन की वजह से आप बोड़ी में लो एनर्जी,
हेवीनेस, ब्लोटिंग या सर्थर्थ जएसे सिम्टम्स भी एक्स्पीरिन्स करने लगे हैं?
लैक्सिटिव्स, चुरन, ध्रिफला, गरम, पानी सब ट्राय करने के बाद भी कोई परमनेंट सलूशन नहीं मिल रहा?
अगर हा, तो आप एक्दम सही जका आए हैं
इस विडियो में आप जानेंगे पाँज शक्तिशाली तरीको के बारेमें
जो आपको कुन्स्टिपेशन को जढ़ से खतम करने में मदद करेंगे
सिर्फ इक्किस दिनों में
आगे आप जानेंगे एक ऐसे हर्ब के बारेमें
जो आपके बावल मौवमेन्स को नाच्रिलेट करता है
और आपकी किच्छन में अभी माईजूत है
और उस एक ऐसी चीज़ के बारेमें
जो कुन्स्टिपेशन में अकसर डोक्टोजा में रेकमेंट करते हैं
लिकिन वो आपकी कुन्डिशन को आख्शवली और ज्यादा बिकार देता है
आये शुरू करते हैं अपने पहले टूल से
आजकल हम वेस्टन टॉयलेट्स यूस करने लगे हैं
जिसमें आपकी बोड़ी और नीज का ऐसे 90 डिग्री आंगल बनता है
अप प्रोब्लम ये है कि इस पोजिशन में आपकी इंटिस्टायन का आखरी हिस्सा आपका रेक्टम बेंट रहता है
जिसकी वजह से वेस्ट स्मुदली पास नहीं हो पाता और आपको बहुत जोड लगाना परता है
इसे लिए त्रडिशनली हमारे देश में इंडियन टॉयलेट्स होते थे
जिसमें हमें स्कॉाट कर के बेटना परता था
इस पोजिशन में बैसिकली वो बेंट पाइट सीधा हो जाता था
और बोड़ी स्टूल को इसली रेलीस कर पाती थी बिना कोई प्रैशर डगाए
अरे चिन्ता मत कीजिये, मैं अपको अप इंडियन टॉयलेट्स अपने घर पे इंस्टॉल करने के लिए नहीं बोलोंगी
आप अपने वेस्टन टॉयलेट्स में भी इस्कॉाट पोजिशन का बेनिफट ले सकते है
कैसे एक फुट्स टूल के जरिये
अपने दब्यूसी के आगे एक फुट्स टूल रख लीजिये
अगर ये नहीं मिल पाये, तो एक बाल्टी को उल्टा करके भी रख सकते हैं
इस से आपकी बोड़ी को काफी हट तक उसी स्कॉाटिंग पोजिशन का फाइदा मिलता है
अब मुझे पता है, आप में सिब कुछ लोक क्या सोच रहे हूंगे?
इतनी चोटी सी चीज़ बदलने से क्या ही फरक पड़ेगा?
वेल, फरक पड़ेगा. इन्फाक्ट, फुट्स टूल पे तो काफी रीसर्ज भी की गए है
जो बताती है कि जिन लोगों ने इसको यूस किया, उनको मोशन पास करने में पहले से सिर्फ आदा समय लगा
उन्हें जोर कम लगाना पड़ा और उठने के बाद उनको बोड़ी में ज्यादा खाली पन और मन में ज्यादा सातिस्फाक्षञ फील होई
तो आप भी आज से ही इस फुट स्टूर को यूस करना शुरू करें
अगले स्टेप परने से पहले एक चीज़ समझना बहुत ज़रूरी है
ये पेट साफ ना होने की प्रोब्लम होती क्यू हैं
देखिये, जब हम शरीर को एक्सर्साइस नहीं देते है
जब हम तादर तर ऐसा खाना खाते हैं जिस में पानी कम होता है
या जब हम बहुत स्ट्रेस लेते हैं
या अगर हम रिपीटेड्ली अपने बोड़ी की मोशिन पास करने की सिगनल को इग्नोर करते रहते हैं
इनमेंसे किसी एक रिजन की वजह से भी शरीर वेस्ट को तंग से एलिमिनेट नहीं कर पाता
नाच्रिरली वो हमारी इंटिस्टाइन की दिवार पर चिपक जाता है
वक्त के साथ हम अपनी आदते तो बतलते नहीं तो ये लेर बरती रहती है
आपको पाता है आपका गोलोन आपकी बोड़ी के हर सेल और टिशू से कनेक्टेट है
अगर यहां गडबड होगी तो वो शरीर के अलग-अलग हिसो में डिस्टर्मेंस लाएगी-ही लाएगी
क्योकि वो वेस्ट अंदर सरने लगता है, टॉक्सिन्स प्रदूस कता है
जोबी हमारा वीकिस्ट अर्गन होता है, ये टॉक्सिन्स उसके फंक्ष्ण इंको डिस्टर्ब करते हैं और उसमें भीमारी लाते हैं
इस्ते लिए तो कौन्स्टिपेशन को मदर आप आप दिसीस पोला जाता है
मेरा आपको यह सब बताने का इंटेंशन सर्फ यह है, कि आप इस प्रोब्लम को प्लीज लाइटली ना ले, तालते ना रहे, और आक्षन ले, और उसको पूरी तरह हील करे
चल्ये, बड़े अपने सेकिन्ट स्टेब पे?
यह है, खुन्सॉम आप लिएस्ट वान क्लेन्जिंग द्रिंक पर दे
अब, मैं आपके साथ ऐसे तीन जुसस और एक स्पेशल्टी के वारे में शेर करने वानी हूं, जो आपके ले बहुत बैनिफिशल होंगे
पहला, सफेत पेथे का जुस, और आश्कार्ड जुस, यह आश्कार्ड आपको किसी भी सब्जी वाले के पास मिल जाएगा
चिल्का और भीज हटाओ, ब्लेंड करो, चान लो और हो गया आपका जुस रेडि
आम्ला जुस, यह आपकी दिजैस्टिफ फायर को बढ़ाता है
जो अलतिमिटली दिजैस्टिन और बावल क्लियरिंग दोनों में हेल्प करता है
तीन आम्ला पानी के साथ बलेंड करो, चान लो, फिक दो तीन बुना जादा और पानी मिलाके पी लो
कोकोनाट वौटर विछ सब्जा सीट्स
कोकोनाट वौटर अपने आप में ही मायर्जली लैक्सिटिव होता है
उसमें एक चौथाई चम्मच सब्जा सीट्स मिला लो
पाँच मिनुट में ही वो स्वेल हो जाते हैं
ये भी आपके गट को क्लिन करें में बहुत मदद करते हैं
और फुर्थ फेनल टी
फेनल यानी सौफ वो स्पेशल हर्ब है
जो आपके डाजेस्टिव से क्रीशन को बढ़ाता है
जिससे आपकी अगनी और इंप्रूव होती है
और बावल्ज और इसली क्यूर हो बाते हैं
फेनल टी बनाने के ले सिंप्ली
आधा टी स्पून सौफ को एक काप पानी में उबाल ले
और फिर कप में निकाल ले
इसको चानने की कोई सरूरत नहीं
आप इन तीन में से किसी भी एक जॉस को
जो आप के लिए इसली अवेलेबल हो
उसको सूबे पी लिए जे
अपने ब्रेक्फुश से एक देड घन्टे पहले
और फिर एक बड़ा टम्लर इस चाइ का बना के रख लिए जे
जिसमें ये गरम रहे
और पूरे दिन आप थोडि थोडि चाइ सिप करते रहे सकते हैं
आप जब हम डॉक्टर्स के पास जाते हैं
वो हमें अकसर एक ऐसी चीज़ प्रेस्क्राइब करते हैं
जिससे शॉर्ट टरम में तो रिलीफ मिलता है
लिकिन जैसे ही लेना बंद करो प्रोब्लम वापस आजाती है
हम बात कर रहे हैं लैक्सेतिव्स की
जब आप इनको लेते हैं बॉड़ी को इनकी आदत लग जाती है
और एक टाइम बाग बिन्ना लैक्सेतिव्द के मोशन आता ही नहीं
हमें इस साइकल में नहीं पड़ना
आपकी इंटिस्टायन को किसी भी चीस की आदत नहीं लगने जाये हैं
ये जूसस और हर्बल टी मा प्रक्रती के नाच्टरल लाक्सेतिव्स है
लेकिन इनकी कभी आदत नहीं लगती
चली बरते हैं अपने थर्ट स्टेप पे
इट मोर वाटर रिच फूट
देखिये, फूट दो तराके होते हैं
वाटर रिच और वाटर पूआ
वाटर रिच वो होते हैं जिसमें रस भरा होता है
जैसे सभी फ्रूट्स
पपीता, तरबूस, खर्बूजा, संसरा, सेब, अंगूर, पाइनापल, बेरीज
और साथ हे स्यादतर सब्सिया
जैसे टमाटर, खीरा, पालक, लौकी, तोरइ, बीन, स्टिंडा
अब दोस्ती तरफ, वाटर पूआ फूट्स में आते हैं
अनाज, डाले और मेवें
जैसे रोटी, चावल, गेहू, डाल, चोला, चना, राजमा, लोब्या, रागी, पदाम, पिस्ता, अखरोत
अगर आप की सीफूट को सिमपली अपने हात में रखो और थोड़ा प्रैस करो
अगर उसने रस निकले तो समच जाना वो वाटर रिज है
और अगर कुछ ना निकले तो समच जाना वो एक वाटर पूर फूट है
अब शायद आप सोच रहे हूँ कि वाटर पूर फूट बोरे होते हैं
बिल्कुल नहीं इनका अपना एक बोड़ी में बहुत इंपूर्टन्ट रोल होता है
प्रोब्लिन तब होती है जब अमारा पूरा दिन सिर्फ इन ही पे चलता है
पर इजाम्पल अगर आप इक मिक्सी में सिर्फ सूखे चीजे डाले
रोटी, डाल, चावल, ब्लेट कितना भी पावर्फुल क्यो नहो
कुछ मिक्स हो पाएगा?
नहीं, लेकिन वहीं अगर बीच-बीच में थोड़ा टमाटर, खीरा और लौकी डाल दो
सबकुछ असानी से ब्रेक्डाण हो जाएगा
आपको समझमे आए में क्या बोल रही हूं?
अपके गट में भी कुछ ऐसा ही होता है
अब सिर्फ ड्राइ वौतर पौवा फौट खाते हो, सिस्टम उनको अच्छे से और जल्डिसे ब्रेक्डाण नहीं कर पाता
उसको निकाल नहीं पाता
दूसरी तरफ वौतर रिज फौट वो मौईश्चो आट करते हैं
जो चीजों को मूव करने में, टाइजेस्ट करने में हेलब करते हैं
अब प्राक्टिकली अपनी डाइट को ज्यादा वौतर रिच बनाये कैसे?
पहला तरीका है फौट बेस्ट प्रेक्फॉस्ट
कौन्स्टिपेशन के लिए स्पेसिफिकली पपाया सबसे फाइदमंद फौट है
लिकिन हां वो अच्छी से राइप होना चाहिए
यह आपकी बोड़ी में प्रोटिन्स को ब्रेकडाउन करने में मदद करता है
और हाट स्टूल को सॉफ्ट बनाता है
इसके लावा सेकिन्ट फॉर्ट जो कौन्स्टिपेशन के लिए फाइदमंद है वो है बनाना
लिकिन सिर्फ तब जब आप सॉबे एक्सर्साइस करते हैं
वरना ये थोड़ा भारी भी हो सकता है
तो ब्रेक्फॉस्ट में आपको एक बढ़ा फॉर्ट प्लाटर देना है
और इसको और फिल्लिंग बनाने के ले
इसके साथ मृत्ठिबर सोक्ट नट्स और सीट्ट भी ले सकते हैं
इसंस्चिली इडली, डोसा, चीला, ब्रेट, टोस्ट, कौन्फ्लेक्स इनकी बज़ाएं
फॉर्ट भेस्ट डेक्फॉस्ट लेके देखियें
आप दिनमें जाता एनर्जेटिक भी फील करेंगे
दूस्ता तरीका, लंज और दिनर में सब्जीयों का रेश्यों को डबल करतीचे
अगर आपकी प्लेट में एक पूर्षन अनाज है, एक पूर्षन डाल, तो दो पूर्षन सब्जी को रखें
बेसिकलि आपकी लंज और दिनर की प्लेट कुछ ऐसी दिखने जाये
तीस्रा, बीच-बीच में ड्राइ या पाकेज्ट स्नाक्स की जगा, हाईड्रेटिंग स्नाक्स लिजिये
जैसे फल, खीरे की प्लेट या स्मूदि
इंशॉर कीजी कि आपकी स्मूदि साथा मीथी नहो, वरना आपका ब्लाट शुगर स्पाइक हो सकता है
एक और फूर्ट जो आपकी गट को नाच्टरली क्लीन करता है
और कुन्सिपेशन के लिए बहुत इफेक्टिव है, वो है प्रुन्स
यानी ड्राइड प्लम्, जिसे सुखा आलू बुखारा भी कहते है
आपके प्रुन्स बिना शुगर कोटिंग वाले होने चाहिया
यह आपको अराम से आउनलाइन मिल जाएंगे
अगर ये प्रुन्स थोड़े भी हाट हो, तो उन्हें कुछ घंटे सुख करके खाए
वरना नॉमली ऐसे भी का सकते हैं
तो ये है तीन अलग-अलग देरीके
अपनी डाइट को और वाटर रिज़ बनाने के लिए
आप फॉन्डमेन्टल प्रिंस्पल समझ गए ना
आपको खाना जादा ऐसा खाना है जो रस्ते-से भरा हो
सिमपल है
अच्छा एक बार जल्दी से उन तीन फॉट्स के बारे में भी समझ लेते हैं
जो आपके गट्ट को सबसे जादा डामेज करते हैं
पहला रीफाइंट फ्लार जैसे की मैदा
इसमें आजाते है वो सारी चीजे जो मैदे से बनती है
भटुरा, नान, पिजजा, पाव, नूडिल, बिस्किट बाकी तो आपको पता ही है
दूसरा, दूद और दूद से बनी चीजे
अप मुझे पता है इस फाक्ट को डाजेस्ट करना थोड़ा मुश्किल है
लेकिन सच यह है कि आजकल के सिदेन्टरी लाइस्टाल में ये डेरी प्रोडक्स हमारा शरीर नहीं डाजेस्ट कर पाता
यह अंदर मुकस पैदा करते हैं
और तीसरा, मीट
इसको पूरा डाजेस्ट होने में तीन दिन तक लग सकते हैं
यह बहुत हैवी होता है और गाट को काफी स्लगइश बनाता है
मैं जानती हूं, आपके लिन को अवोइट करना तोड़ा मुश्किल हो सकता है
हम फामिलीस के साथ रहे हैं, बाहर जाना होता है
लिकिन जितना हो सके, आप इनका कंजाम्षण कम खीजे
त्रास्ट मी, आपको इंस्टिन्ट रिसाल्ट्स दिखेंगे
आप सोच रहे हूँगे, मैं यह सब इतने खुण्फिडेंस से कैसे बोल सकती हूं
बिचले आट सालो में, मैंने हसारो लोगों को देखा है
जिननोंने इनी स्टेप्स को फॉलो करके, अपने गट इशूस और कुंस्टिपेशन को रिवर्स किया है
चली उनमेसे कुछ लोगों से मिलते हैं, और फिर बढ़ेंगे
इन बढ़ेंगे बैदवा विवाविज्ट पर प्रोब्लेंगा तो अब बीता घाए
आजगार्ट दिएउस कियो, प्रॉट खाओ, तो मैंने ये सब त्राइकिया
पंदरा दीं के अंदर अंदर मेरे सारे प्रॉब्लब दो गया थे
तो मुझे लिए जल्डी टाइरिस्ट हो रहा था।
आश्डार्जूस आथिंग आज रेली हेल्ग नहीं।
जितना आप अपने शरीर के लिए कैर करोगे,
वो भी आपको उतना ही कैर करेगा।
लाइफ बहुत इजी हो गयी है।
आपको खुद फील होगा कि आप अंदर से फ्रेश फील कर रहे हैं।
मुझे लिए जल्डी टाइरिस्ट हो रहा था।
आइये, बरते हैं अपने फौर्थ स्टेप पे और वो है मूवमेन्ट।
आपके आपके अच्छी है। ये तो आपको पता है।
लेकिन फिर भी मैं आपके लिए दो निज़े स्टाइज लिंग कर रही हूं।
जो क्लियर नहीं बताती है, कि लैक आप मूवमेन्ट और कुन्स्टेपेशिन का कितना बड़ा लिंक हैं।
आपको इस विडियो में कोट करी हर स्टाइज का लिंग निज़े दिस्क्रिप्षिन में मिल जाएगा।
वैसे तो सभी एक्सर्साइस वाइदमंध हैं।
लेकिन आपके गट के लिए कुछ स्पेसिफिक मूवमेन्ट हैं जो एक्स्टर बैनिफिशिल हैं।
जैसे त्विस्टिंग आसनास, पस्चिम्मृत आसन, मरीच आसन, अर्द मत्सेंद रासन, मल आसन।
अगर आप सोच रहे हैं, ये सब करेंगे कैसे तो हमारे पास आपके लिए एक स्पेषिल गिफ्ट हैं।
हमने अपने योगा चानल पर एक 30 मिनिट की विडियो अपलोट करी हैं, जिसमें ये सारे आसनास इंक्लूट करे हैं।
चाहें आप एक बिगिनर हो या अलगरी योगा प्राक्टिस करते हो, आप इसे देख कर साथ में प्राक्टिस कर सकते हैं।
अपने विडियो का लिंक आपको निज़े डिस्क्रिपशिन में मिल चाएगा।
और अगर आपको लगता है कि अरे योगा तो मुझे होगा है नहीं, कोई बात नहीं।
आप ब्रिस्क वॉकिन करे, कोई सपोट खेल ले, डान्स करे, साइटलिंग करे, वो मॉवमेंट करे जो आपके दिल को खुश करे।
पर मुझे सूबा काम पे जाना होता है, इतना सब करने का टाइम कहें।
हूँ... अगर टोक्टर कहे, कि आपके हाट में ब्लोकिज है, तो सब सीरियस हो जाते हैं.
अगर दिमाग में ब्लोकिज हो, पूरा परिवार पानिक हो जाता हैं.
विंट पाइट में ब्लोकिज हो जाएं, तो सब को छोर चाढड के हौसपिटल भापते हैं.
तो फिर gut में blockage को इपना casually क्यों लेते हैं?
जबकि that is the mother of all diseases, even mental health problems.
तो इससे लिए आप ये माच जोचिये, मेरे पास तो ये सब करने का time नहीं हैं.
आप life में जिस चीस को prioritize करेंगी, उसका time निकला जाएगा, सच में.
बरते हैं अपने constipation healing plan के last step पे, अभी तक आपने ये चार चीजे सीखी हैं.
अब मैं सच पताओ तो ये चार चीजे काफी हैं, अगर आप implement करते हैं, आप एक हफते के अंदर अंदर ही changes देखेंगे.
लेकिन ये last step उनके ले हैं, जो और स्यादा fast results चाते हैं.
और वो है abdominal wet pack followed by enema.
Wet pack एक बहुती simple tool हैं, जो nature cure का part हैं.
एक थंदे white cotton के कपड़े को आपको 30-40 मिनट के लिए अपने abdomen पे राब्ट करके लगाना हैं.
लगा कर कोई भी और काम कर सकते हैं.
जब ये wet pack लगाते हैं, बोड़ी में दो temperature मेंटेन होते हैं.
जहां wet pack लगा हैं, वो part थंदे, बाकी शरीर घर्म.
इस से blood circulation बरता हैं.
और जब blood circulate होता हैं, तो toxins, waste जो intestine के अंदर जमा हुआ हैं,
वो भी थीरे थीरे अपने जगा छोड़ने लगता हैं.
और body से निकलने के लिए तयार होता हैं.
Wet pack लगाने के बाद, अगर आप enema ले तो आपको double फाइडा मिलेगा.
Enema के त्रू आप अपने rectum में थोड़ा पानी डालते हैं, उसको hold करते हैं.
और ये पानी अंदर जाके waste को lose करता हैं, और बाहर निकालने में मदद करता हैं.
और हाँ, वैसे तो enema आपको एक chemist shop में मिल जायका, लेकिन आपके ले इसको और convenient पनाने के लिए,
हमने इसको अपनी website पर भी अवेलेबिल किया हैं.
अगर आप enema या wet pack order करना चाते हैं, तो यहां खलिक कर सकते हैं.
और अगर आप enema की पूरी विधी समझना चाते हैं, तो यहां खलिक करें.
और आप wet pack के बारे में और सीखना चाते हैं, तो यहां.
मैं आशा करती हूं, कि आप ये steps follow करके अपनी constipation को पूरी तरह heal करेंगे.
अभी के लिए इतना ही, हम जल्द वापस मिलेंगे.